da un partito che sono fuori campo ciao
ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata
di vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è a un anno dalla quarantena
un'apocalisse zombie un'invasione aliena
e la mente di l'era glaciale
chi l'avrebbe detto che a metterci in
ginocchio sarebbe stato uno starnuto che
avrebbe mai pensato che avremmo
trasformato le nostre dimore in palestre
pasticcerie e panifici e parrucchieri o
qualsiasi altro mestiere vi venga in
mente con api ma non è più vecchio del
mondo che io ho saputo ci siamo laureati
mutanti abbiamo seguito lezioni in
pigiama e abbiamo partecipato a
videoconferenze in accappatoio tutto ciò
per evitare il lanciafiamme dello
sceriffo è stato un anno difficile
soprattutto per noi cattolici che non
sapendo distinguere i colori non
capivamo la differenza dal lunedì al
martedì e al mercoledì e tutto quanto
uguale ma io dico chi ci pensa a noi
abbiamo capito tante cose a volte
pagando un prezzo troppo alto
abbiamo capito a cosa serve la macchina
abbiamo capito come la marcia e
finalmente
le mani e che se li ricordava quei
pollici abbiamo capito una cosa più
grande e importante di tutte le penne
dice servono solo ad occupare spazio
sugli scaffali del supermercato vi prego
toglietele dal commercio i balconi sono
stati trasformati in discoteche
patriottiche allestite per aperitivi
conditi da cartelli motivanti e grida di
buon auspicio per me se gli infermieri
uno stelo hanno penetrato più narici di
tutti gli attori di pollica che tra
parentesi ci hanno tenuto compagnia con
un mese di lezioni gratis chi avrebbe
mai detto che avremmo seguito ogni
giorno alle 17 degli idioti in costume
che ci mostravano con i baci ed è per
questo che all'interno degli studios di
casa mia ho deciso di invitare il mio
fratello gabriele potresti usare bambi
per presentare l
noi abbiamo vissuto molte emozioni
durante vicissitudini quest'ultimo anno
è per questo che ho voluto the richiesto
di massimo impugna la barca che fu di
poterla bandiere la bacchetta e fammi
vedere un wingardium leviosa ingardi un
leviosa a bacchetta si impugna soltanto
in modo ogni cosa
l'anno scorso all'inizio del primissimo
lockdown stalla voti nder perché non
avevo una mazza da fare pochissimi
giorni dopo ho conosciuto un ragazzo ma
non avrei mai pensato di incontrarlo
perché sinceramente mi teneva compagnia
durante le giornate di quarantena quando
poi è stato possibile a vedersi abbiamo
cominciato a frequentarci ci siamo
innamorati e questa ragazza adesso il
mio ragazzo stiamo assieme da nove mesi
non lo voglio lasciare più se non fosse
stato per il coronavirus e forse non
avrei mai installato tendere non lo
avrei mai co marketing ha veramente poco
poco poco da offrire un posto di morte
cerebrale e la mira e speranza perché io
sono dell'idea che in realtà le app di
incontri possano servire ragazzi questa
quarantenne le ha fatto bene un tono
possiamo dire ridondante uno stile
ampolloso per me il lock down è stato
fisico da covi non ho più smesso mi
alleno ancora tra volta alla settimana
8 che i lingua in due mesi il mio corpo
è cambiato incredibilmente e soprattutto
la mia mente perché ho scoperto che
lavorando sul corpo può cambiare anche
la mente rivedo omero prima frattempo
sono diventata mamma e lo ero diventato
un budino vedo le sfide con una forza
incredibile voi siete un punto fermo e
lo sarete nella mia vita per sempre un
ricordo meraviglioso vi ringrazio non mi
ringrazierò mai abbastanza anche più
simona per noi è proprio così
l'allenamento fisico è un'abitudine che
prima di tutto far star bene mentalmente
quando la mente sta bene sta bene tutto
il resto indipendentemente dal tipo di
corpo che tu hai è un qualcosa che è il
risultato semplicemente del tuo impegno
del renderti conto cai una forza
decisionale sulla tua vita io per
esempio non ce l'ho in questo guarda
anche a me capita di avere periodi più
se dovessi chiedono solamente 12
addominali abito dove si aveva tutti e
ventisette
ciao bob io sono quella che l'anno
scorso giocava a guardie e ladri nel
palazzo a vienna ti ricordi ed ora la
mia vita è cambiata in modo radicale
sono dovuto rientrare in italia per
forza e ho dovuto cambiare mestiere come
sai la ristorazione è completamente
ferma da mesi ho cambiato settore ho
messo a frutto la mia patente nautica
lavoro come scritto era vado in barca
tutti i giorni e sono felice è stata
stata un'altra cosa la l'anno scorso
avevo iniziato a fare un po di attività
grazie al fisico da copit non ho mai più
smesso di fare attività fisica rete e
tutta la wind family perché avete
collaborato al fatto che non era più il
culo vediamo le cose positive del 2020
anno difficile divisione che cosa faccio
nella difficoltà avviene il cambiamento
la mutazione l'adattamento la voglia di
rivalsa la metamorfosi lo sbocciare in
stile ampolloso un tono ridondante e
nonostante l'improperio dell'annata
scoperta investigatrice scoperto che mio
padre tradiva mia mano a breve mentre
anni e mezzo è rappresentata a settembre
2019 ha rappresentato come unica ma da
quel giorno fa su hulk avuto il sospetto
così in quarantena con la scusa della
dar dovuto il suo computer è stato tutto
conversazioni foto eventi insieme lei
niente nessi mista forziati 1 nostri
figli non sono cretini due vedono tutto
tre perché le fate questo perché sul
matrimonio non funziona tu ti senti di
dover panna cosa così e vivere nella
vita parallela di tutto io volevo sapere
come poi è venuta fuori la storia
diciamo se l'ha detto lei oppure lei ha
messo davanti al padre il problema c'è
ma non è paragone fatto è che lei magari
andato dal padre il padre non so se ha
fatto di dirlo fu grazie alla distanza
dovuta alla quarantena ho scoperto le
innumerevoli corna che il mio ragazzo mi
aveva fatto in tutto questo io in questo
2020 ci dovevo andare a convivere quindi
perdonatemi per questa quasi bestemmia
ma ringrazio e covip per non avermi
fatto fare questo passo madre santissima
dello studio della morte questo periodo
ha aperto gli occhi a un sacco di gente
e ad altri invece li ha messi
all'angolino gli ha fatti crollare nelle
loro ceneri l'anno di difficoltà funge
da divisorio scala alcol muretto presto
dall'altra parte del muretto
con due frasi riesce a riassumere con un
nostro file ampolloso esuberante ciao a
tutti ciao guglielmo ambiente almeno non
è cambiato niente perché stando in
america nel quale abbiamo acquistato
molto di meno non abbiamo fatto un vero
e proprio lockdown io c'ho prosa fisico
da gov.it però mi mettevo in casa fa
pizza e pasta fatta in casa mi sono
cullata sul fatto che non potendo
venirmi da l'ho detto ma chi se ne frega
del fisico io mangio se state mela salto
e adesso però che sta mettendo in forma
sperando di birra più presto in america
ve la siete vissuta meglio somma è una
percezione diversa i numeri sono
terrorizzati un'api non entriamo nel
merito e nel discorso perché non è
proprio la sede giusta avere neanche la
sedia giusta che aveva gara botto fa
schifo cazzo dice 46 dei mille euro e
che fanno cagare sono di classica
ragazzi sono anti the science sono
bellissime
allora non devi toccarla 250 euro e bene
ma di opere su queste sere di quello che
ho fatto un lady corpus cresciuta che se
la prendereste il [ __ ] quelle in
legno quelli col corno che bevi tipo il
tredicesimo guerriero con la ciotola che
passa col pisello di fuori questa
ovviamente è mezza natura non vive al
caso tuo a febbraio mollava una persona
veramente speciale e dopo una relazione
di 10 anni
favolosa perché è purtroppo abbiamo
smesso di condividere la stessa idea di
futuro ovviamente a marzo il devasto
lockdown li volevo partire per l'estero
e mi hanno cancellato il volo grama vero
però mi laureo 110 e lode e senza dover
uscire da camera mia
trovo un lavoro pazzesco da remoto uk ma
luglio riesco a prendere un volo venire
qua in inghilterra dove sono tuttora e
adesso sto pure con un napoletano
meraviglioso che lavora e vive qua pure
lui legate e speranza per tutti e
sperate di avere anche un po di culo che
non brucia la gola così proprio non va
nessuno non c'è fortuna è vero a un osso
e cosa gabriele lei e in seguito il suo
sogno con grande coerenza con stile
ampolloso sarà caricato gli improperi e
aveva fatto luci degli improperi
niente abituati a dire come lui era mai
che culo che c'è uno che ha inventato un
lavoro quando non esisteva che certo non
mi ricordo quanti anni fa sala scrivania
così faceva tutte cagate così è certo
punto ho visto uno stile ampolloso però
benissimo anche ringrazio che del
segmento prima domanda come si uccide un
dio è un alloggio da tipo ansa importare
il ragazzo di vengano queste cazzate che
a breve ma tu sei tipo una ti sento mi
sembra una persona procace con questa ma
che vuol dire persona procaccia con
cuffee se dovessi scegliere uno
strumento da portare con te su un'isola
deserta porteresti un rasoio che può
essere utilizzato solo per il pube un
libro scritto in una lingua che non
comprende o un pacco da 100 di tampa xvi
assorbenti no no italia su quelli per le
stampanti a loro sta prendendo tempo
che cosa è il rasoio bella declinato nei
vari dovessi rimanere l'ultimo essere
umano sulla faccia del pianeta
preferiresti girare ogni giorno a
pisello di fuori anche d'inverno o
essere costretto a cambiare ogni giorno
abitazione dormendo vicino ai resti
umani con tempo abitavano
quell'abitazione sarei anche abituato al
mire vicine resti umani cioè sono
l'ultimo dormire vicino ai resti umani
acquisendo per l'uomo
se dovesse uscire di casa per
procacciare il cibo preferiresti
inoltrarti in un supermercato molto
fornito ma con maggior rischio di venire
attaccato o in un panificio compagni
stantio e un goccio d'acqua nel quale
sei più sicuro di non beccare un nemico
ovviamente la prima allenamento
combattimento a ogni fatto la presa del
dito se ti trovassi davanti un parente
che è stato trasmutato che avessi la
possibilità di crivellarlo di colpi o
scappare lasciandole in piedi quale
sceglieresti è difficile che rivelarlo
di colpi e roche lo lasci soffrire lì
così forse l'ok river plate 1 livello
tipo hai trovato una dose di cura e sei
stato morso da uno
preferiresti usarla per te o sola
persona che cada su una persona a me
cara è vero che quella persona senza di
me e durerà poco è spacciato pure lui
non si farà vocalista tra vendola con
per celegato normale alloggi mi guardava
non era morto preferiresti che in giro
ci sia un virus che sostituisce i tuoi
genitali con quelli dell'altro sesso
oppure un virus che sostituisce mani e
piedi costruire una pagina con 2 10 da
un pugno scappi da una pandemia letale
tre anni dopo torni dal luogo da cui è
fuggito preferiresti trovare persone che
stanno bene che si sono dimenticati e
totalmente della tua esistenza persone
che hanno subito gli strascichi di un
evento devastante che ti avevano dato
per morto e quali si è mancato ogni
giorno della loro vita che si sono
dimenticate felici ma è soffrite capri
tema non dimenticatevi di me per l'aiuto
ai visto il mio nome di armi nastro navi
sono pronte a distruggere il tuo pianeta
natale vengo inviato io dove spera di
salvare la terra allena brody aria ne
racca 2000 astronavi sono pronti per
salvare la terra saresti disposto ad
accoppiarsi con la totalità dei piloti
intergalattici oppure abbandonare il
pianeta terra e salpare verso un luogo
misterioso nel quale una popolazione che
non capisci non conosce che ti
disgustati venire era come il proprio
messi ha ritrovato sa assolutamente la
seconda tipo un anno una copa tra liuc
che hanno preso padre luca breve grazie
mille per aver giocato con segmento come
c'è un video c'è una principessa
nascosta in ognuna di noi come far
parlare un attimo
oggi sembrano ripetersi e tutto ciò che
sai ministro lui sa cosa deve fare scusi
ma sei pazzo
penso che c'era proprio il bellissimo e
le rose di peluche rava l'ho amata
geniale geniale libera libera in stile
ampolloso tra l'altro ho visto uno
spettacolo ridondante grazie grazie per
questo video si può dire lo faccio più
schifo di prima dopo un anno di distanza
ha imparato ad essere più reale faccio
schifo conta non me ne frega un caxxo di
nessuno presentata l'individualista mi
sono accorta che in quest'anno tutte
quelle che come la nikon e non lo sono
quei 4 milioni e mi ritengo ben ben
scritti amo i miei cani è un altro paese
che siamo a casa in quarantena perché
misurata la pavia il mondo
fondamentalmente fa schifo ma
fondamentalmente va bene così possa
essere felici con un po meno tutti i
giorni e ballo sarei vino e quindi basta
minchiate fa tesoro bacino poi schifo
anche di fare scriva che aveva a
qualcuno non mi va manco di mandare
questa nota che lei per la libera libera
come si può essere altruisti se prima
non si è individualisti partiamo dal
nostro schifo iniziamo ad apprezzare
trasformazione ridondante altruismo
augurami a quarantena comincia un anno
fa a milano rende una macchina col mio
cane che un bruto francese come il tuo e
tornò in calabria in calabria una casa
al mare quindi mi chiudo in questa casa
normale col mio cane
il wi fi tutto quanto però deciso di
staccarmi dai social nel cd legge di
studiare di divertirmi fare attività
fisica e la morale che durante la prima
quarantena ho perso 15 chili ma ho
recuperato un anno e mezzo di esami
adesso vivo la vita in maniera
completamente diversa io ho ottenuto
soltanto e dicesse qualcosa di brutto
quel bulldog francese pure il vero
tristissimo di colpo cade proprio a
pizzi solido non lo voglio più parlare
io ho sentito la storia di un'infermiera
49 anni si è iscritta a infermieristica
a 40 anni lei ha 40 anni ha cambiato la
sua vita è stato un messaggio bellissimo
di speranza non è mai troppo tardi per
poter fare quello che vuoi noi ragazzi
c'è sempre tempo ci si preoccupa sempre
di divieti dei cartelli che non ci si
metteva in cammino come scrive
l'università gli in cammino subito dato
in gioco il cazzo faccia canna devo
cambiare vita
non mancherà nessun allarme rosso
all'albero saw v di stato rientrando
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video che belle grazie mi avete
cos'è un bar a un bar è un barboncino
tenendo su tutti quanti voi che ci avete
seguito fino adesso lasciateci un bel
pollici su commentate commentate
commentate iscrivetevi al canale
attivate da campo nelle notifiche noi ci
vediamo domenica che la puntata di
cucina buttata aleggiato ciao
tu devi parlare e non è importante
l'inizio ma alla fine ma tu riesci a
farlo tranquillamente
io ti pare non inizia a parlare
vabbè non serve ancora un pannolino
perché tu devi anticipare dire
col kakashi sensei e poi lo sharing non
pagare il caso non dire non era
tantissimo
voglio sparire con gli sparire
non posso anche per tenere la stretta mi
fai fare